هذه الدبابه وهذه الفرقه المدرعه تشارك
منذ بدايه الحرب في العديد من المعارك
ليس امامها هؤلاء الجنود سوا دقائق معدوده
لتحميل الذخيره قبل التوجه الى موقع
التهديف
تم وضع الدبابه في موقع الرمي المحدد نقوم
بادخال احداثيات الهدف ثم نقوم بالتنفي
الاصابه وتعديل الاحداثيات اذا تطلب الامر
[موسيقى]
طائره مسيره تنفذ طلعات استطلاع فوق
المنطقه المستهدفه لرصد رده فعل القوات
الروسيه والتعامل معها
هذه صور حيه للمنطقه قامت برصدها طائره
الاستطلاع وهي عباره عن خنادق لمقاتلين
روس يتحسنون في قريه على بعد ثمانيه
كلمترات من موقع نشاط هذه الدبابه التي
تقوم بقصف متزامن مع قصف مدفعين لنفس
الهدف
تمكنا من اصابه الهدف علينا ان نستمر ننهي
المهمه
من السكان
مروحيه اوكرانيه تصل الى المنطقه وهي
بدورها تقوم باستهداف المواقع الروسيه
نستفيد من توقف قصف المدفعيه الروسيه
للعوده الى قاعده الفرقه المدرعه شارك
هؤلاء المقاتلون في العديد من المعارك منذ
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي وكان
الكثير منهم في منطقه خرسون عندما استولى
عليها الروس
ايه نحن بحاجه للحصول على دبابات متطوره
مثل ابرامز الامريكيه الفرنسيه البريطانيه
بهذه الدبابات سنتمكن من تحرير خيرسون
وحتى جزيره القرم والعوده الى حدود عام
2014 بذلك سنضع حدا للقتل الجماعي الذي
تمارسه روسيا ضد شعبنا
لم تتوقف كيف عن مناشده الدول الغربيه